so viggo this feels like a family
vacation for you you were here in 2012
on the road with kristin and you're back
with david cronenberg this must be a
special place for you well it's the best
the most important film festival in the
world
and so you have it's well you know yeah
as well as i do that it's you have the
best of movie making and the most
i don't know if it's the worst but the
most grotesque and weird things you see
here on the street
three blocks and you're like wow
i've had my fill going back to my hotel
right now no it's beautiful and what's
the best thing is
if you're lucky and you have to be very
fortunate and make a very good movie
to be invited to competition
you know there's i don't know how many
are there a dozen or fifteen yeah
of thousands and thousands of movies
attempt to
to be here every year
and he's been here several times you
know he's one of the
living masters of world cinema i guess
and so anytime you're here though it's
it's good fortune you know to be
included i would have been happy to be
here just to see him come back after
eight years just whether i was in the
movie or not but to be part of the story
um
it makes it extra special and i'm
looking forward to tonight to see how
people react how people react when i
watched this film i had to adjust to
what i was watching had to assess the
situation
in your own words what is the vision
that cronenberg was creating for the
conversation for audiences to have
i think he wants people
maybe i i really don't think he makes
movies
to create a reaction
or to shock or you know
some people feel differently maybe but
whether it's this movie or crash or any
other movies made
he's actually dealing with subjects that
interest him
you know
always he's dealing with mortality
always he's dealing with the effects of
the environment and the effects of the
actions people take in their lives on
their own bodies
unflinchingly you know
aging decay injury
whatever
whatever happens whatever we do to
ourselves he always looks at that very
honestly and with a sense of humor i
think and that's the case of this movie
i i i think maybe
maybe i'll be proven wrong tonight but i
think people are more prepared to
we'll have more open minds than they did
say back when crash was shown here
to his way of thinking
maybe what's happened in the world in
the intervening
quarter century
wars illnesses technological advances
you know
uh covid all of it yeah
climate change maybe people are more
open to what the things he's talking
about in the story
than they would have been say 10 years
ago or 20 something when he wrote the
story and you and cronenberg have such
an incredible relationship and chemistry
but this is a different film it's like
the og of david cronenberg how was it
this time around
well i knew he would be
he would help me i know he would make it
fun which he did
what was different was with his help
trying to play a character that was more
like reactive
i wouldn't exactly say
passive but he's
reacting to what happens to his body and
what happens
around him how people react to the
performance art that he does with
you know his partner caprice
most of all he's reacting to what's
happening to his own body yeah you know
as a result of environmental factors
and
the evolution of his own you know
physical system
and the other roles i've played with him
are more
active i guess so yeah it was a good
challenge as an actor i kind of liked it
because you know when you think about it
good acting is is based on good reacting
and so that's what i was doing i was
reacting to what other people
were feeling seemed to be
saying or feeling about what we were
doing
and i was mostly reacting all the time
to
difficult you know at least playing that
difficulty with breathing
that is so true eating
yeah
you know not being able to sleep because
feeling pain and you know how do you
play that so working with david he
helped me find sort of a way to not
overdo it so that you're kind of wow
that's really weird the way he sounds or
you know what i mean he's moving his
body you want to do it
to the point where you realize that it's
happening but you don't want it to be
overwhelmed
what the scene is about so that was a
interesting dance
which he helped me with
crimes of the future what are the crimes
of the present
as always the biggest crime is not
paying attention
well said
to your body
to what's happening in the environment
and to how your actions above all affect
others
that's always the biggest crime pretty
powerful thank you so much
you